hi there steve kaufman here again
today i want to talk about
staying in the moment when we learn
languages
um
you know
there's you can google and look up
living in the moment staying in the
moment
and i think today it's so easy to be
distracted uh it's easy to be distracted
when you're on a computer and have
access to the internet to your email or
to
other places you want to go
it's easy to be distracted by
thinking of
maybe mistakes you made or
things you want to do tomorrow or
frustrations with your language learning
so
i find that it's very important to to
develop that ability to be in the moment
when we are enjoying our language so for
me that might mean
uh when i'm
linking a korean text or i'm reading a
ukrainian text
um that i want to basically block
everything out and just enjoy it
i find now too that i'm sort of
semi-retired
um of course i have a lot of memories of
things but i try not to spend my time on
the past or the future i like to sort of
say wow look at the colors even in this
room
uh the texture of what i'm looking at
um
the sound of the rain outside
just to seize that moment
and to have that kind of an attitude
when you're
enjoying your language listening to it
or
even writing or if you're communicating
with someone just have that sense of
that enjoyment of that moment
don't think about
like i don't recommend that you should
think about wow i'm doing this because
later on it'll improve me that's why i'm
i'm not such a big fan of you know anki
or these other skills where i'm doing
something which is drudgery now but
somehow i think it's going to improve me
i don't tend to think that way i say i'm
doing this now i enjoy it i'm learning
about korea i'm enjoying the sounds of
korean
i'm enjoying that
i happen to know
that this is going to help me
gradually absorb the language i haven't
know that i'm going to just by the mere
fact that i'm exposing myself to more of
the language and reading
and
paying attention to words i know that's
going to help me but i'm not thinking
about what it's going to do for me in
the future i'm only thinking of enjoying
this task while i'm doing it
i find that i've become actually better
in doing that because of my experience
as a language learner so even if i'm
reading spanish now
where i have had trouble with verb
endings as we all do in spanish and
because i'm in the moment i tend to
notice okay this is the third person
singular of the past tense which i
sometimes have trouble with and i kind
of notice it just like
that little tick i noticed i'm in the
moment
that's going to help me i don't think
about how it's going to help me i just
know it's going to help me and so i just
stay in that moment of enjoying the
language so
just a bit of advice i could go on much
longer but i'm trying to keep my videos
short try to enjoy the moment for what
it is rather than for what it might do
for you or thinking about previous
failures or anything else
just enjoy the moment thank you bye for
now